around 12:30 Saturday afternoon drivers
along 176 Street in Golden ear's Way in
Su couldn't believe their eyes when they
saw a large green tractor hogging the
road shortly followed behind them two
RCMP officers with their lights and
sirens on uh following the tractor and
one of the police cars already had some
significant damage to it obviously where
the tractor be making contact the two
were actually BC highway patrol cars
they stayed cot on the tractor's tail
what we saw is the tractor made contact
with the police car a couple more times
before finally uh making contact and
actually rolling over the door is ripped
off the tractor flipped the tractor
flipped the farm vehicle swerved onto an
exit Lane for Highway 1 and crashed
operator a tractor driver fell out of
the sunroof of the tractor onto the road
there RCMP tell global news that several
emergency crews attended and one man was
taken into custody the suspect was also
taken to hospital but he did not suffer
any life-threatening injuries from what
I understand from uh listening in as
closely as I could I think he was
protesting uh he started out in chillak
or he owns a farm in chillak and he was
actually driving down Highway 1 uh
protesting not too sure what the driver
may have been part of a protest the
tractor appears to have an anti-i flag
on the
[Music]
back this week there have been several
protests surrounding the BC education
program known as SOI which stands for
sexual Orient orientation and gender
identity Global was contacted by a
member who told us a stop soi1 123
protest was planned for Saturday a
poster made for the road rally said they
plan to drive from chilak to Vancouver
he's fcking hitting the C sir RM P say
the BC integrated Collision analysis and
reconstruction service will be
investigating as the tractor driver
turned into the police car that's
actually what called him caused him to
roll over I'm not an auto body guy or
nice BC guy but I think that one's a
right off Julia Foy Global News